[Musique]
infos intox avec Antoine fenaud bonjour
Antoine bonsoir Raphaël et une nouvelle
info ou plutôt une infox elle concerne
la guerre en Ukraine et le président
ukrainien volodimeki absolument Raphaël
au tour d'une visite très précisément du
président ukrainien c'était dans un
hôpital de quai il venait alors
rencontrer des soldats blessés lors des
combats c'était le 13 mars dernier
plusieurs médias notamment occidentaux à
la relayer pour l'exemple j'ai choisi
pour vous celui-ci donc on voit la
petite séquence qui a été un peu coupée
il faut bien l'avouer de volody
merzelinski qui donc va rencontrer les
soignants il sert les mains il va voir
les soldats qui qui sont blessés
notamment problème selon certains et
bien le média russe RT notamment cette
vidéo serait ancienne car la femme qu'on
voit au tout début c'est un peu plus
c'est un peu coin vous l'avez la petite
la femme blonde que vous voyez juste
derrière volodimeki et bien en fait elle
s'appellerait Ina dérou sauva et elle
serait décédée en février dernier
comprenait et bien cette séquence n'est
pas de la date qu'elle est la date
affichée du 13 mars
donc le média russe qui est RT notamment
qui est désormais interdit en Europe
depuis 3 mars dernier a fait un tweet
justement que avec ce petit montage que
vous apercevez ici il l'affirme
notamment que et bien c'est la vidéo
n'est donc pas de la date qu'elle prêt
et qu'elle prétend et que cette femme
que l'on aperçoit donc à côté de vos
diverselenski dans une autre séquence
que je vous montre un peu plus tard et
bien c'est celle qu'on voit à droite là
qui est apparemment décédé c'est en tout
cas ce qu'affirme également un autre
compte Twitter cette fois-ci en russe
qui reprend là encore le même montage
avec le président ukrainien cette femme
blonde à ses côtés et donc cette cette
ce photon montage avec cette page
Facebook et notamment l'info
l'information en tout cas la prétendue
information a également été relayée sur
plusieurs comptes francophones notamment
celui-ci que j'ai choisi pour vous vous
le voyez c'est Unis qui est publié une
vidéo dans laquelle il aurait visité un
hôpital aujourd'hui avec des soldats
blessés des forces armées ukrainiennes
avec une femme
décédée le 28 février celui
par exemple la formation a d'ailleurs
été reprise et c'est assez important
pour le signaler par des médias russe
notamment celui-ci qui cite un député
ukrainien pro russe notamment il y a qui
va qui affirme que cette vidéo ne fait
que renforcer les doutes sur la présence
de volodimeersky à qui a rappelé vous
rafale on avait un temps accusé le
président du crayon d'avoir fui au début
de l'invasion russe la capitale
ukrainienne le but vous l'aurez compris
et bien c'est de d'insinuer que vos
données des meilleurs Zelinski à cette
fois définitivement suit la capitale et
que la vidéo est très ancienne en résumé
bien c'est un exercice de propagande ça
sent comme la fausse info oui absolument
et pour l'affirmer il faut se pencher
sur l'identité de la femme qui
accompagne donc volodime en zenki la
femme blonde que vous avez aperçu un
petit peu plus tôt et ça tombe bien
parce que le gouvernement ukrainien a
publié sur son site web des photos de la
visite du président ukrainien on va
s'intéresser à celle-ci que j'ai choisi
pour vous on y voit la femme que vous
voyez donc ici qui est reprise
soi-disant comme étant décédé aux côtés
du président zininsky en 11 mois un peu
un peu vous alors je suis au maximum du
zoom mais vous voyez son écusson
militaire au milieu de la poitrine c'est
son grade on voit également apparaître
sur cette petite une espèce de petite
barrettes comme beaucoup de militaires
ont qui est le nom qui leur nom qui le
qu'elles affichent sur la poitrine la
femme nous a un fond intox on l'a
retrouvé son grade et bien elle est
titulaire du grade de général de brigade
son nom c'est Tatiana otachenko et elle
est commandante du service médical des
forces armées ukrainiennes c'est tout à
fait logique puisque
un hôpital on a d'ailleurs retrouvé sa
photo la voici vous la voyez de
meilleure qualité sur la page Facebook
du service du commandement du service
médical des armées ukrainiennes la photo
elle date de juillet 2021 on la
reconnaît donc bien sur cette photo elle
n'est donc pas décédée et la vidéo elle
est bien récente en revanche et pour
être tout à fait complet Raphaël sachez
que l'infirmière mentionnait dans la
soi-disant en formation par les médias
pro russe et les comptes Twitter elle
est bien décédée en opération c'est
cette femme ci que vous apercevez ici
elle s'appelle donc Ina déroucé Val est
infirmière elle est mort tenant
l'exercice de en fonction c'était le 26
février 2022 a actirka c'est dans la
région de soumis les médias Ukrainiens
donc vous lui apercevez d'ailleurs
relayé elle a d'ailleurs été nommé
héroïne de l'Ukraine à titre posthume
avec d'autres mondes des forces armées
ukrainiennes c'est la page du la
présidence du la présidente ukrainienne
et son nom apparaît juste ici en
cyrillique vous pouvez l'apercevoir donc
voilà encore une fois un bel exemple de
désinformation qui se base cette fois
sur une vague ressemblance physique
rafale vous l'aurez compris merci
Antoine Antoine fenot c'était info intox
restez avec nous dans cinq minutes un
nouveau journal dans Paris direct
[Musique]